no nos gusta tu forma anticuada de
hablar de hacernos de menos de no
dejarnos entrar
y no nos gusta la forma adecuada de
estar callada y plantada detrás de ver
las pasas
somos buenos somos más somos fuertes y
capaces
soñar sin nada
y
[Música]
para que esté bien
sin pensarlo
sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
podemos afuera
y eso
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
y la noche no estaba del miedo ya no
hermanas ya es hora nos toca luchar
somos viento somos tierra son más
fuertes y capaces de
grande
el corazón
y ya estamos hasta de verdad
[Música]
12 millones de aquí
antonio cambiar
[Música]
podemos hacer algo más y no para solo
mirar y así no tener que escuchar
[Música]
escuchad a esa voz que nos está llamando
se está haciendo grande restringirán
el dolor en cada parte alimenta
su olor con cada golpe con cada muerte
que no queremos ni una más tampoco ni
una menos nosotras somos las que somos
buenos y seremos mujer de piedra mujer
con fuerza mujer afrenta altiva bien y
esta mujer que grita de mujer que
escucha mujer que avanza con fuerza
[Música]
y que como cuenta
y
[Música]
no no
sí
[Música]
al qaida
millones de años aquí
y queda tanto por cambiar
[Música]
siento que un poco que podemos hacer
algo más
[Música]
losada
millones de años
[Música]
y
podemos hacer algo más
no sólo a mí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias gracias este tema se
llamaba sonoridad y habla de la mujer
así que ya sabéis buscarnos en todas las
redes sociales ahí está lo acabamos de
estrenar y ahora vamos con otro y ya os
dejamos con lo que queda de las charlas
muchísimas gracias a toda la gente de
télex por contar con nosotros otra vez
gracias ha sido un placer estar aquí
seguimos esto es para todos vosotros
[Música]
ahora que habéis comido algo me dais
unas palmas
arriba
[Música]
en esta sala
mi vida
ese estuvo
cuando dijo la masa grasa en su interior
la verdad
preparar su cuerpo y seremos
comentó que su
y es que debería acabar
sabe dónde está
m
[Aplausos]
ah
y
[Música]
las obras piezas de pan
dañar el intestino entrañas y algo más
la diablada
era intensa y nadie le responde ese
pueblo para buscar
esa paz que tengo el cuando de algún
paso de empezar
aguirre sombra
el señor
que bajar y no puedes debería acabar no
sabes
ah
[Música]
él
la estrella puede hacer
sí
y la verdad
[Música]
ah
no sabe
mal
[Aplausos]
alarte las tres partes
de pagar nada
[Música]
así que sus movimientos a la del aire
elefantes por lo que a lo dicho
muchísimas gracias te des muchísimas
gracias a todos los que estáis aquí
gracias a todos nos vamos disfrutadas a
blatter
no está nada mal
[Aplausos]
las nubes
[Música]
él
qué
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]